good evening welcome to washington i'm
brett baer breaking tonight growing
concern about americans and those who
helped americans still stranded in
afghanistan as anecdotes of new taliban
atrocities are filtering out of that
country the bond administration is
trying its best to turn the page from
the issue that is fueling accusations of
broken promises from the president we'll
take a closer look at that in a few
minutes also tonight dozens of
republicans are now calling for the
president's impeachment over his actions
and this phone call with the afghan
president before the fall of kabul but
impeachment is something the top gop
senator says
will not happen white house
correspondent jackie heinrich starts us
off tonight live in the north lawn good
evening jackie good evening brett on the
third day since the troop withdrawal no
answer on whether any more americans
have made it out of afghanistan or how
many green card holders or siv
applicants remain the white house is
directing those questions to other
departments and there's a distinct
feeling president biden is trying to
move on from afghanistan to his domestic
agenda
there's a lot of damage president biden
addressed the nation about storm
recovery but gave no update on
afghanistan and took no questions from
reporters as more than 100 americans and
countless at-risk afghans who helped the
u.s in the 20-year war remain behind
enemy lines there are people who are
eligible we may not even know they're
eligible yet right it is very hard to
define those numbers meanwhile accounts
of reprisals those afghans face are
getting more dire this person said they
killed 12 members of special forces in
kandahar three soldiers in jalalabad as
well the taliban took them out of their
homes and shot them given this kind of
reporting that we're hearing is it
possible that our reliance on the
taliban to keep their word in terms of
our evacuation is misplaced we're going
back on things like the amnesty promise
no one is saying from the federal
government no one the president
secretary of defense known from the
intelligence community that the taliban
are good actors that is one of the
reasons we are being so clear that we
are not rushing to recognition politico
reports shame among anonymous sources
inside the white house one person
telling politico i am absolutely
appalled and literally horrified we left
americans there kabul's airport remains
inoperable and the white house says
there are risks associated with charter
flights seeking to extract americans to
u.s military bases we do not have
reliable means to confirm the basic
details of charter flights including who
may be organizing them we know isis k
has a keen interest in attacks against
aviation targets and our personnel on
the ground
in our air for in our military bases
among the house gop growing calls for
the president to resign but the top
senate republican mitch mcconnell says
president biden will not be impeached
and the ballot box is a better place to
hold him accountable
still other republican senators want
accountability now 25 members wrote to
president biden saying while they
disagree on whether troops should have
remained in afghanistan they're all in
agreement president biden's chaotic
withdrawal caused this crisis spread
jackie obviously the administration the
president want to focus on domestic
agenda items
but you have this human infrastructure
bill that's kind of sitting out there
the 3.5 trillion a key senate democrat
is pretty much blocking that path
that's right west virginia senator joe
manchin said there is no way he will
support that three and a half trillion
dollar social infrastructure package
that democrats want to pass along party
lines he dragged his colleagues for what
he called a strange belief there's an
infinite amount of money to go around he
wrote democratic congressional leaders
proposed to pass the largest single
spending bill in history with no regard
to rising inflation crippling debt or
the inevitability of future crises
ignoring the fiscal consequences of our
policy choices will create a disastrous
future for the next generation of
americans without mansion's vote biden's
agenda really seems to go nowhere and it
appears that mansion is dug in brett all
right we'll follow that jackie thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else